let's count together from 0 to 19.
so we have 0
nine
and now we go to the two digit numbers
and then we go to 10
15 16
and 19.
now why did i do this well the whole
point of this is to see a pattern here
especially in these two digit numbers
what do we see is true about all of
these numbers that are you could think
of them they're being in their teens
well they all you might see have a one
as their first digit
and that one is sitting in what we'll
call the tens place it literally says
that each of these numbers that one
represents a ten what do i mean by that
well if we go up to ten over here this
is telling us
that this one represents ten and then
this 0 represents 0 ones
so 10 is 10 plus 0. you say oh well
what's the big deal we already knew that
any number plus 0 is that number again
but i think you'll see the pattern as we
go into these other numbers
so 11 is equal to
so this one the yellow one represents
ten and then this pink one represents
one
and then twelve twelve
this yellow one represents ten and then
this pink two represents two or you
could you could think of it as this
yellow one says this is one ten so we
have a ten right over there and this is
two ones and you have two right over
there and we can keep going i think you
see the pattern thirteen is ten plus
three
thirteen is ten plus three fourteen is
equal to ten
plus four
plus four fifteen
is equal to 10 plus
5. i encourage you to pause the video
now and try to finish the rest try to
write 16 17 18 and 19 as 10 plus some
other number and really just make sure
that you understand the pattern that's
happening
so let's do that so 16 so i can even
write them all like this they're all
going to be 10
10 plus something
so 16 is 10 plus 6
17 is 10 plus 7
18 is 10 plus
8 and 19 is 10 plus 9. and when you
write it out like this it becomes pretty
clear that this 1 in each of these
numbers represents 10
and then the
digit on the right that just represents
that many ones